bachelor couple Ben Higgins and Lauren
Bushnell are hosting a wedding special
from the castle in Disney World
yeah it's been more than a year since he
proposed so what we wanted to know is
what is going on with plans for their
big day we get it like people are
interested in winter we're getting
married we're excited for that day but
we don't know we don't know our life is
pretty crazy and we're having a blast
being engaged while the bachelor couple
isn't ready to say I do just yet they
did get some inspiration hosting
Disney's fairytale wedding special I
always thought that I wanted a small
wedding honestly even like a low fee and
then I see this beautiful wedding
pavilion inside with the view of the
castle complete this is so beautiful I
could see myself getting married here
we were behind the scenes as the
acapella group pentatonix performed live
while the bride arrives in Cinderella's
carriage Pentatonix's hear about lost it
boycott the same one Borya used four
years ago with 30 cameras all around the
park the brand-new TV event took 4
months and 500 people to plant Erik and
Ruby actually got married seven years
ago their first wedding was a rush it
was at a courthouse he got called to go
and serve our country in Iraq and now
Erik's back and he wants to give his
bride the most special wedding husband
and wife had a once-in-a-lifetime
experience the big finale
a giant waterworks display in front of
the ferris wheel but when it comes to
Ben's favorite part of the festivities
the cake my sole goal with the wedding
now is to make sure we have a good cake
the icing is really smooth
[Music]